in order to slay
kosher the immortal one must first find
his soul
which is hidden in another body inside
of a needle
inside of an egg which is inside of a
duck that is inside of a
hair inside of a golden chest buried
underneath
a green oak tree and if somehow you're
still following
that tree is on the mysterious island of
bouyon
which disappears into the ocean
i think you get the point his soul is
almost impossible to find
and that made him very hard to kill
hence the name and the topic of today's
episode
as we take a look at the story of kosher
the immortal
and how he finally met his demise
as powerful as kosher may have been
there are a few things he wasn't capable
of
like browsing the internet without being
at risk of having his details and
personal data stolen
or in his case the location of his soul
however with today's sponsor surf shark
you do have the power to hide your ip
address from prying eyes and browse the
web
safely without any annoying pop-ups and
malware
you can even disguise your ip address as
one from another country
giving you access to all sorts of
content that may have been
otherwise restricted if you live in the
uk like me then you'll know that our
netflix
is terrible with surf shock you can
change your location to another country
and get access to all the good tv shows
and movies
maybe you just love danny devito and
always sunny as much as i do
in that case you can change your
location to the uk
and have access to every season if that
sounds good then you can click on the
link in the description
or use code mythology when signing up to
get a whopping
eighty five percent discount you also
get an extra three months for free
as well as a 30-day money-back guarantee
and there is no limit to the amount of
devices you can use surf shark on
so if you want to appease the trash man
then check them out
in a land far away existed a
sorcerer an evil sorcerer who terrorized
the land and struck fear into the hearts
of its people
this wicked man took several different
forms and presented a
grave threat to even the most formidable
hero
he feared only one thing in all the
kingdoms
and that was death itself and so
he cast a spell one that would allow him
to transfer his soul into another body
and essentially cheat death with his
soul hidden where it could not be
found he could continue his reign of
terror with
impunity kosher the sorcerer was no
more the name people would instead
hesitantly whisper
was kosher the immortal
many brave warriors tried to slay coche
but none were successful it was the
warrior princess
maria morevna who defeated kochei
but without knowing where his soul was
located
they couldn't kill him instead he was
locked away in the
tallest tower of her castle bound by
heavy chains and left to wither away
from
thirst and starvation for eternity never
to regain his power
or at least that is what the princess
had hoped
but there are some things in life we
cannot control
the protagonist of our story is prince
ivan
one of four children before his father
died
he made ivan swear and he would look
after his three sisters
and ensure they found good husbands
one morning in the courtyard of the
castle an eagle
swooped down in front of yvonne's
sisters and transformed into a
handsome prince he was followed by a
crow
shortly after and then a raven
these three wizards had come looking to
wed yvonne's sisters
after questioning the men who stood
before him to honor the promise he had
made to his father
yvonne turned to his sisters and asked
if these were the men they wished to
marry
each one nodded and flew off to their
new kingdom
leaving ivan alone for the very first
time
as the years passed he grew more and
more
impatient until he was eventually
overcome by his desire for adventure
ivan ventured out of his kingdom with
the intention of visiting
all three of his sisters but along the
way yvonne came across
a camp of soldiers who invited him to
join their feast
celebrating their latest victory
to show his gratitude ivan entered the
tent of their
leader but he was surprised to see a
beautiful
warrior princess maria morevna
and as you do in these types of stories
they fell instantly in love
and were married with the excitement and
change he desired
yvonne decided he would move to the
princess's kingdom
and all was good until war
found itself on their doorstep
the princess had no choice but to leave
ivan
and defend her people but before she
left she told yvonne
her kingdom was now his and so was her
castle
he could go wherever he pleased except
for the room at the very top of the
tallest tower
no matter how curious he became she
urged him to stay as far away as
possible
and so the princess went off to war
leaving her kingdom
in the hands of ivan and for a while
he did as promised but as he grew lonely
that need for adventure that spark that
fueled his curiosity would soon be
ignited once again
yvonne waited until most of the castle
had fallen asleep and snuck his way into
the tower
expecting to see something horrifying
something not of this world a cursed
treasure perhaps
he swung open the door and paused
confused and
a little disappointed nothing but an old
man
bound in chains please kind sir
won't you take bitty on an old man
i've not had a sip of water or a morsel
of food
for what feels like 10 years
yvonne took pity on the man and fetched
him a bucket of water
watching as it disappeared in seconds
one bucket is nos enough to quench my
thirst
please i need more
yvonne fetched another and another
hmm yes i can feel my throat blaring
please kind sir won't you spare just one
more for a dying old man
still wondering why he was forbidden
from this tower
he fetched the old man one last bucket
of water
when he had finished drinking the old
man cleared his throat
you prince yvonne are a fool incapable
of following a
simple command if it is an adventure you
so
desperately seek an adventure you shall
have all of a sudden the old man sprung
to his feet
no longer weak and timid the chains were
broken
now ivan knew why his wife warned him
he knew of the man who stood before him
kosher the immortal
ten years i have waited for the woman
who trapped me here to return
and now thanks to you i am free to exact
my revenge
you will never see your wife again as
long as i
live and with those last words kosher
dove through the open window flying
through the sky in the shape of a
whirlwind
ivan's heart began to sink as he
realized he may never see his wife again
but his self-pity lasted only
momentarily
this was all his fault he swore he would
see his wife again
although ahead of him was a long and
dangerous adventure
a quest that made ivan finally feel like
he had a purpose
yvonne traveled for over a year from
kingdom to kingdom
trying to find where kosher had taken
his wife
his sister's husbands all gave him a
trinket
so if he was ever lost they could find
him
eventually he learnt kosher had taken
her to his palace
deep inside the forest a place few ever
dared to go
yvonne arrived in the dark of night and
decided it would be best to wait until
he saw crochet leave
when morning came and he saw the wicked
sorcerer leave on his horse
he knew he would have to be quick to
save his wife
when he entered the castle it was his
beloved wife who lay there in chains
this time
forgive me my love i have been bested by
my own curiosity
ivan apologized you have a kind heart
ivan
but not every day can be a grand
adventure
sometimes the quiet days are the best
now you have left yourself with no
choice but to find a way to stop kosher
we can stop him together ivan smashed
the chains and helped his wife to her
feet
he'll be back soon and we can't outrun
him his steed is the fastest in the land
then we must leave now they hurried to
ivan's horse and rode back through the
forest
but their tracks would soon be found by
cauchy steed
why have you stopped beast forgive me
master
it is prince evan he has the princess
and they are riding through the forest
then let us catch ourselves a prince
shall we
as you wish master poche hissed at his
horse
a sign that it was time to quicken the
pace
as hard as yvonne tried his horse could
simply not outrun
kosher it wasn't long before kosher
overtook them
and knocked them both of the horse and
onto the ground
i told you prince ivan you will never
see your wife again
but i admire your bravery and so
this time you may leave go
back to your miserable life and remember
this act of kindness
for if you dare to return i will cut you
into pieces and throw them into the sea
kosher picked up the princess placed her
on his horse
and rode to his castle
ivan wandered the forest for days alone
and dejected he took a seat on a tree
stump
and placed his head in his hands after a
short while
a bird appeared and sat down next to
ivan
why do you sit here looking so glam when
the sun shines so bright
the bird asked koshay the immortal has
taken my wife
i shall never see her again and it's all
my fault
and if she were in your position would
she give up so
easily no she would try again
and again even if it meant death
then you must try again prince ivan
before ivan could ask
how the bird knew his name it flew off
into the tree line
ivan knew he couldn't outrun kosher in
his steed
but he returned to the castle anyway and
waited for kosher to leave once again
his wife was what he found her before
now in a new set of chains
maria we must hurry i don't know how
long we have before kosher will return
oh yvonne why have you come back
this time he will kill you
then we mustn't get caught this time
they hurry to yvonne's horse and rode
into the forest
crochet's horse stopped in its tracks
the prince has returned master this will
be the last time i
deal with this fool for a while it
seemed as if they avoided crochet
but before they could clear the forest
he found them
and when his horse overtook them they
were knocked to the ground
well it is a pity but perhaps what i
thought
may have been bravery was in fact
stupidity
take a good look at your wife yvonne
it will be the last chance you get
and with that kosher kept his promise
he cut ivan into pieces placed them in a
barrel
and threw them into the sea the trinkets
ivan had been given would now have their
use
as they were made of silver when ivan
died they turned
black letting the wizards know evil had
overcome the prince
the eagle was able to find the barrel at
sea and drag it onto shore
the falcon returned from the waters of
life and the raven from the waters of
death when they were reunited they took
ivan
out of the barrel and placed him back
together the best they could
the raven then poured the water of death
over a van
until his body reformed and became whole
again
the falcon then sprinkled his body with
the water of
life and devon opened his eyes and began
to speak
how long have i been asleep for i must
get back to maria
rest eager prince the falcon told him
we found you in pieces left to the mercy
of the sea
as much as you may want to race back to
kosher's castle
we cannot guarantee this spell will
bring you back a second time
heeding the ravens warning yvonne waited
he would have to be smarter this time
when he returned to the castle it was
not to rescue his wife
instead he asked her to inquire where
cauchy found his steed
and so the princess tried something not
many had done before
she had a conversation with kochie
forgive me for asking but where would
one acquire such a magical steed
in all my travels i've never seen
anything like it
that is because one must travel to the
thirteenth
kingdom thrice nine lands there one will
gaze upon a river of fire when it is
crossed you will find the home of
baba yaga she has a mayor who can travel
across the world in a day
i watched her herd for three days
without losing a single mare
and my reward was a horse of my choice
but how does one cross a river of fire
this handkerchief is enchanted three
waves at the edge of the river
and up pops a bridge out of the fire's
reach
and where enough i am rather
tired perhaps i will answer more
questions tomorrow
later that night the princess took the
handkerchief from the table
and handed it to ivan the next morning
she told him
everything kosher had told her and
yvonne began the next step of his
journey
the wizards had drawn yvonne a map of
the thirteenth kingdom
and so he traveled for several days
before reaching the river of
fire his horse would go no further
when he got to the riverbed he took out
his handkerchief
in his right hand he waved it above his
head
three times and just like kosher had
said
the bridge appeared allowing ivan to
cross safely
once across the bridge he walked for
hours
until he came across a small bird and
thought to himself
it's been so long since i last ate this
bird will make for a fine meal
please prince yvonne do not eat my child
and i will owe you a good deed
yelled the bird's mother and devon
carried on walking
he then came across a beehive and
thought to himself
i need to eat something maybe i'll just
take some of this honey
please prince evan do not take my honey
and i will owe you a good deed
said the bee and devon carried on
walking
he then came across a sleeping lying cub
and thought to himself it's been so long
and i feel
so unwell this cub will make for a great
meal
please prince yvonne do not eat my son
and i will owe you a good deed
pleaded the mother and once again yvonne
continued walking weak and hungry he
stumbled on
until right there in front of him was
the hut of baba yaga
surrounded by a picket fence of human
skulls
he walked into the garden and as he was
about to knock
the door flung open come
child let me see
you yvonne stepped forward into the
house
sitting at the table was an old decrepit
hag
is this the heart of baba yaga
i have many names
but you have a certain
royal smell who are you and what do you
want my name is yvonne and i have come
because i need a steed as fast as the
one you gave kosher
ah yes i remember
the sorcerer vile individual he was
and yet you still gave him a horse i
merely made him a deal and he honored
his end of the bargain
for you prince yvonne i offer the same
deal
take my herd and watch over them for
three days
if they all return you may choose
whichever horse you desire
however if you fail and even one does
not return
i will add your head to my collection
outside
ivan nodded knowing full well that it
wouldn't be easy
why else would she offer him food and
rest before
on the first day yvonne took the horses
into the field
once they passed the gate they galloped
in all directions
leaving yvonne to chase after them a
hopeless endeavor
with the horses out of sight ivan had
failed on the very first day
by nightfall he had fallen asleep on a
stone slab prince evan
wake up the horses are back in the
stables
the bird yvonne had met earlier had come
to fulfill
its good deed when ivan returned to the
stable baba yaga was
livid shrieking at the horses
why have you returned home we had no
choice
we were chased by a flock of birds who
almost gouged out our eyes
well tomorrow would disperse into the
forest and do
not return home this time
overhearing this yvonne knew she never
intended for him to complete this task
the next morning he was woken by babies
wake up young prince my horses won't
take themselves out
remember if you lose just one
your head shall join the rest outside
yvonne needed no reminder of the stakes
as he prepared for the second day
ivan took the horses out into the field
again
and just as they passed the gate they
dispersed
again but this time into the forest
yvonne was left to drown his sorrow and
the same slab of stone
prince evan do not despair i have
collected all the horses
this time it was the lioness who had
come to fulfill her good deed
ivan returned to the stable to see baba
yaga
shrieking at the horses again only this
time
angrier why have you returned this time
i told you to stay in the forest
we had no choice there came a lioness
who chased us back home
well tomorrow when the prince takes you
out you
disperse into the blue ocean and you do
not
dare to come back home the next day the
process repeated
and the horses dispersed into the ocean
sitting on his stone behind ivan flew a
bee
prince ivan the horses have been
returned to the stable
but this time when you return hide in
the back of the stable
there is a stallion waiting when the old
hag goes to sleep you can steal the
stallion and ride away
if you do not she will kill you in the
morning
when the horses returned they were again
questioned
why have you returned this time my
instructions were simple
we had no choice when we entered the
ocean we were stung by a swarm of bees
they chased us all the way home
useless creatures i shall see that our
prince remains a
permanent fixture of my fence
yvonne came out of hiding in the back of
the stable and
found the horse but it didn't seem like
a fine stallion it was weak and frail
how could this be any match for crochet
steed
disappointed ivan untied the horse
anyway feeling
sorry i've come for the fastest deed in
all the land
but i fear that is not you i
am the fastest stallion in all the
kingdoms but that wicked hag starves me
and locks me away
but why because she knows when i'm
strong i will escape and she will never
catch me
if you help me we can escape together
and after i'm reunited with my wife you
will be as free as you desire
the horse gave yvonne a nod ivan jumped
on its back and they rode as quickly as
they could to the river of fire
once there ivan waved the handkerchief
but in his excitement
he waved it above his head only twice
and so the bridge that emerged was much
thinner than the first time
behind ivan he could hear the screams of
baba yaga
when she woke to find her prize stallion
missing
she jumped in her pestle and mortar and
gave chase
only a fool would steal from me boy
i will grind your bones into dust
yvonne and his steed hurried across
as babayagar zipped by them her pestle
was caught in the rope
and she lost her balance falling out of
her mortar
and into the river of fire where she
died
a gruesome and rather fitting death
over the next few days ivan fed the
horse
and allowed it to gallop across the open
field
until it had regained its strength in
front of him was a
fine stallion perhaps the finest he'd
ever
seen he could only hope it was enough to
outrun kosher
he rode to the castle and was once again
greeted by his wife
i thought surely you'd be dead but if
kosher catches us then you will be
then let us hurry and see how fine this
steed
really is crochet's horse stops suddenly
what is it yvonne has returned master
he has the princess again then let us
pursue
the steed was hesitant this time he has
a steed even faster than i
then i repeat let us pursue
kosher gave chase as he drew closer ivan
steed began to slow
when he was ready to knock them off
their horse it was ivan's horse who
struck first this time
knocking kosher to the ground ivan and
maria dismounted and drew their swords
in a gust of wind the sorcerer lunged at
ivan
his horse drew his hind legs back and
bucked
cracking crochet skull and immobilizing
him
with kosher struggling on the ground
they hacked away
chopping him into pieces just as he had
done to ivan
but even still his decapitated head was
able to speak
i cannot die i am caution the immortal
maria turned to yvonne and agreed it is
true
his soul is in another body in a land
unknown
then we burn his body and scatter the
ashes into the ocean
his head will be placed in a wooden
barrel left to float the sea
forever and if he finds a way to return
then we have a new adventure we will
travel to lands unknown and
find his soul to end his reign
and so they did as they said his ashes
were scattered into the ocean
and his head thrown into a barrel to be
watched over by the
eagle falcon and raven
and that is the story of kosher the
immortal
and how he finally met his demise
but if kosher cannot die then what
happens when he is forgotten
and there is no one left to guard his
remains
surely his return is no longer a matter
of if
or maybe but when
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
you